l'on sait que la faille informatique
arbres lead a fait des dommages environ
900 numéro d'assurance sociale ont été
copiés de son site web qu'est ce que ça
veut dire qu'est ce que ça signifie on
en parle avec françois daigle qui est
vice président des services
professionnels chez au crioc qui est une
firme spécialisée en sécurité de
l'information monsieur daigle de bonsoir
bonsoir bon tout d'abord quel escroc
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire qu'est-ce que
l'individu qui vole un numéro
d'assurance sociale
peut faire juste avec le numéro sans nom
on ne peut pas faire grand-chose au
numéro d'assurance sociale c'est un
identifiant qui sert à faire plusieurs
transactions financières fiscales etc
mais le numéro en soit s'il n'est pas
associé avec un individu avec un nom un
prénom
voir éventuellement avec une adresse il
est le numéro en tant que tel est ce
qu'il peut nous mener vers le nom de la
personne wisair l'adresse de la personne
et là c'est là que sa puce gratter ses
les regroupements de base de données son
vol numéro d'assurance sociale à gauche
avec un peu d'informations nom prénom et
on vole l'information dans un autre
système informatique où on a le nom
prénom et l'adresse l'on peut regrouper
tout ça est tranquillement on peut bâtir
un profil qui permet aux fraudeurs de
voile et votre identité faire des
demandes de cartes de crédit des
demandes de prêts financiers il est des
choses comme ça mais numéro en seul le
numéro d'assurance sociale c'est très
difficile de faire quelque chose avec ça
comment est-ce que revenu canada a pu
être en mesure d'identifier qu'en ce
moment là parmi tous les contribuables
et millions de contribuables canadiens
qui possèdent des numéros d'assurance
sociale qui en a seulement que 900 à
l'heure actuelle dont le numéro a été
volé est ce que ça vous apparaît chef
conservateur est réaliste ou réaliste on
a plus d'informations sur comment ils
ont identifié ce nombre là ils ont émis
un communiqué de presse qui dit que des
autorités policières ont leur ont fourni
de l'information en informatique établir
qui a eu faim et que q
un bris de sécurité relié à cette faille
là pendant une période très très limité
c'est assez de soutenir cette thèse le
moi j'ai plus l'impression que c'est les
corps policiers les crs les gendarmes y
re royale du canada qui ont mis leurs
gens l écoute sur les réseaux sociaux
sur les réseaux un peu plus obscurs de
pirates informatiques des possiblement
quelqu'un ses ventes et moi j'ai réussi
à exploiter la faille je l'exploité
jusqu'à quelle heure et là ils ont pu
établir à pendant six heures il ya
quelqu'un on est sûr que quelqu'un que
voler de l'information savoir qu'est ce
qu'il a volé l'or c'est un travail qui
est de longue haleine parce que les
doigts vous regardez toutes les
transactions qui ont été faits dans le
passé pendant cette période là et voir
effectivement ce que c'est seulement des
relations sociales ce que ça peut être
autre chose actuellement on a très peu
d'informations qui peut nous porter
accord que plus que d'une mes relations
sociales mais ce que l'on comprend selon
revenu canada l'agencé de revenu du
canada c'est que ces gens-là c'est 900
personnes là vont bénéficier de mesures
de protection assez exceptionnel alors
c'est peut-être les citoyens dans ces
circonstances c'est possiblement les
citoyens les mieux et plus choyés et
puis les mieux protégés oui mais c'est
parce que là ils vont bénéficier d'une
protection les et les agences de crédit
vont faire un suivi de leur numérotation
sociale de leurs profils financiers etc
ici il se passe quoi que ce soit
l'alertent va être levé alors ils sont
quand même très bien protégés et
maintenant que le gouvernement a dit que
ses cadres ces neuf cinq numéros de son
social là serait monitoring et la valeur
de ses cartes de crédit la sur le marché
noir est quasiment nulle parce que ne
pas un fraudeur qui vont s'y risquer de
faire une fraude avec des numéros dont
il sait que tous les radars sont en
train de chercher un numéro d'assurance
sociale ça change pas comme ça du jour
au lendemain elle il faut cesser cet
avis bref ces champs je ne voudrais pas
avoir changé mon numéro d'assurance
sociale c'est
ces cinq à sept ans
lorsque là c'est pas de profil c'est pas
de permis de conduire c'est tous vos
presse votre ferr régimes de pension
c'est tout au tout alors vous changer ça
c'est sûr que vous alliez toujours
pouvoir la personne qui est obligé de le
changer va pouvoir prouver que c'est
pour lui le fraudeur et y expliquer son
son cette situation sauf qu'à chaque
fois que vous allez faire un prêt une
demande de prêt hypothécaire la question
vaut toujours lui revenir comment ça se
fait j'ai deux numéros d'assurance
sociale comment ça se fait que vous avez
ça et là chose certaine cette faille
démontre à quel point nous sommes
vulnérables face à l'informatique et
faut demeurer extrêmement prudent et je
m'imagine qu'il ya des des murs coupe
feu qui vont de voir s'ériger pour
éviter d'autres problèmes genre monsieur
d'agde merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous merci merci au revoir